en la excursión pasada fuimos a una
montaña y la subimos con unos chips que
registraban nuestros movimientos cada
quien subió a su ritmo algunos hicieron
varios descansos y otros subieron más
rápido al final todos llegamos a la cima
como parte de la excursión nos dieron
las gráficas con el tiempo y la
distancia que recorrimos sólo que las
revolvemos y no sabemos de quién es cada
una ayudan a saber a quién le pertenecen
la información que tenemos es la
siguiente
la agua recuerda haber hecho dos
descansos en el trayecto y el primer
tramo lo recorrió muy rápido miguel tuvo
una trayectoria muy constante dice que
avanzaba un tramo y descansaba otro
tramo igual y descansaba no recuerdo
cuántos descansos hizo pero fueron
varios además de que fue el último en
llegar a la cima gabriela tomó un
descanso y después subió casi toda la
montaña tomó otro descanso y subió la
pequeña parte que le faltaba con calma y
yo hice tres descansos recuerdo haber
visto a mis amigos más adelante así que
el último tramo lo recorrí más rápido y
sin parar para alcanzarlos con esto
veamos cada gráfica y determinemos de
quién es cada una
los descansos los identificaremos con
líneas horizontales ya que indican que
el tiempo siguió pasando pero la
distancia no se cambió es decir que no
avanzamos ni retrocedimos esta primera
gráfica tiene tres descansos y la última
parte está más vertical esto indica que
se avanzó una distancia mayor en menos
tiempo entonces esta gráfica es mía ya
que yo hice tres paradas y el último
segmento lo recorrí muy rápido la
siguiente gráfica es esta llamar que los
descansos y el tramo de mayor velocidad
recuerda nuestra información pertenece a
gabriela porque tenemos dos descansos y
el segundo tramo es el que se recorrió
más rápido vemos la siguiente sólo
faltan las de laura y miguel esta
gráfica indica dos descansos y el primer
tramo es de mayor velocidad así que es
de laura' eso quiere decir que la última
gráfica es de miguel' sólo comprobemos
que tiene muchos descansos y que todos
los tramos fueron a una velocidad
constante y si mira como parece una
escalera por qué
los avances fueron iguales muy bien
ahora vamos a hacer nuestra propia
gráfica imaginando que somos unos
alpinistas profesionales y que sabemos
escalar muy bien como tenemos una
excelente condición física subimos muy
rápido la primera ladera de la montaña
en muy poco tiempo recorremos mucha
distancia nos detenemos porque vemos que
alguien necesita ayuda unos metros más
abajo
así que descendemos auxiliarlo retomamos
nuestro andar y subimos aún más rápido
para compensar el tiempo que bajamos
sólo nos falta considerar el tiempo
invertido en ayudar cuando bajamos así
que trazamos una línea horizontal antes
de volver a subir listo hicimos una
gráfica de movimiento si tuviéramos los
datos exactos de cuántos metros se
subieron o bajaron en cierto tiempo sólo
habría que trazar la de acuerdo con esa
información cuando veas una gráfica de
este tipo podrás interpretarla sin
ningún problema